I don't have a set of deep formalized
religious convictions I think a lot
about the biggest existential questions
you know why are we here and what are we
doing and so on and so forth and you
know I don't know if you ever heard that
story about Gertrude Stein she was on
her deathbed and she said she said what
is the answer and she was told there
wasn't any answer and she said well in
that case what is the question and I
think we all ask ourselves what's the
question what's the answer and so forth
and as best I can tell the answer is
family the answer is love the answer is
love of country love of family all the
things that really make our lives
worthwhile and what are we going to
leave behind what is our legacy going to
be there's a phrase that I like a lot
what did you do with the dash so you
know on your tombstone it's going to
have your birth date and your date of
death and in between there will be a
dash and the question is what you do
with that time in between what did you
do with that dash I think that's the big
question I have a fierce political
philosophy and it is independence I
really despair when people start off by
saying you know I'm a conservative and
therefore where I'm a liberal and
therefore you know let's privatise
something or big government is best I
just got into this discussion the other
day with Newt Gingrich and what I say is
if you're a business person if you're in
the military if you're a football coach
if you're anybody a mother how do you
think you think about what's the problem
to be solved and that's where the way we
have to be we have to be pragmatic so I
think of myself as a centrist as a
pragmatic problem solver and I wish we
could get our political leaders to put
aside all this ideology and think about
problem solving be a centrist be
independent
I think the young have a responsibility
to the old and very definitely older
people have a responsibility to the
young there's no question every
generation has to be responsible to the
other that's what that's what society is
built upon and you know there was a
congressman who came to the AARP bored
one day and he said you know that young
people have to pay for older people to
receive Social Security and I'm going to
go out and talk to young people and I'm
going to make them madder than hell
about this and of course there is no
intergenerational warfare in this
country he was he was dead wrong they're
young people are interested in their
parents and their grandparents and as I
said before vice versa we have to all
care about each other and if we do that
we'll be a better society well I think
there's a formula and the formula is not
a deep secret either the way to age well
i think is to stay mentally and
physically active and then the obvious
things you know eat well don't smoke
those kinds of things get plenty of
exercise but mental and physical
activity are the most important things
that people can do to age will